trying to reintegrate back in society
was a hard process harder than that I
thought it would be my name is Tito
Ramos I served in the Marine Corps from
2006 and to 2011 I was in the US Army
for seven years and I was deployed to
Iraq and Afghanistan I am a United
States Marine
I served in Iraq from 2006 through 2007
I'm a Marine Corps veteran I served from
2002 to 2012 served in Iraq and
Afghanistan of three tours in Iraq and
two tours in Afghanistan I served in the
Marine Corps from 1999 to 2004 I'm
currently serving in the United States
Air Force I've served five tours
overseas once equates three to
Afghanistan and went to Africa that I
joined right out of 18 I grew up in LA
you know not a not a pretty good
neighborhood for me it was joining the
military was sort of an outlet just to
get out of that situation I wanted to
serve I want I wanted I wanted to serve
this country country dad's given me and
my family so much especially being sunup
immigrants out to the US it really
really meant a lot it also gave me a way
to grow up learn cy was challenge myself
really these are people that come from
all different walks of life they're all
part of a team we're all a family
it's a beautiful multicultural mix of
people who come together and love and
support each other and you know fight
sometimes to the death with each other
one thing I learned the most from my
deployment experiences is that you know
like you have a voice everyone has a
voice and you have a responsibility to
speak your truth I realized damn I
really got my family everyone my
brothers my sisters my parents and
medium you know we didn't get along
before I left I realized how important
they were so I learned about a lot about
that about myself the kind of person I
want to be the kind of husband kind of
father I wanted to be and what kind of
leader I want to be realizing that the
world did not really necessarily
Revolver
around America everyone had your own
cultures I learned that it's tough on
families it's really tough to just get
up and be away for you know anywhere
from three to three months a year
getting out the military is very very
hard I don't care if you serve four
years or forty years in the military it
is a very very hard transition hardest
thing about returning to civilian life
especially coming back from a deployment
and it's just the adjustment period you
know when you deploy you sort of have to
detach yourself from everything but you
know when you return you know it's kind
of jumping back into that mode it's
sometimes not not easy to do another
lady had worked it walked up and said oh
are you gonna go off sergeant on us my
god what what do you mean like yes I was
a sergeant I understand what you mean
yeah you're gonna go just start yelling
at people and hitting us or like why
would I do that like that that makes no
sense like they don't understand yes I
was in the Marines but no I I don't
bring it all back with me I'm not even
in the Marines I didn't just yell at
people or just hit someone because they
were wrong I'm an adult I just don't do
that I still don't sleep
get maybe two to three hours of good
sleep at night screams never go away
at times it feels like oh you were in
the military you know you you're not as
smart as other people or you know you've
experienced these things so you must be
broken give him some time
there was gonna be hype of it
hyper-vigilant help them use that
internal energy and moving towards a
very positive goal short-term goals to
set short-term goals and you started
completing those one at a time then you
realized holy crap I just graduated from
count